Continuing where we left off at the very
beginning of the Book of Knowledge
from Riyadh as Saliheen
the chapter regarding the virtue of
knowledge
those who teach it
those who learn it
both teaching it and learning it for the
sake of Allah.
As we mentioned before the author at
half of the Nawawi
began this book this Book of Knowledge
here
with four verses four select verses from
the Quran. Now are the virtues of
knowledge
are there more than just four verses in
the Quran regarding the virtues of
knowledge? Of course, they are in the
tens they are in the dozens perhaps even
in the hundreds.
However
these are select verses
which capture the essence of what the
author is driving towards.
And the narrations that will follow,
they are all
, lined up and they are all
, working around that center thrust of
this ,
book
and chapter which is the virtue of
knowledge.
So, he mentions four verses. The first
one we've already discussed in Surah
Taha,
in which Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says,
[Arabic recitation]
in which Allah teaches our prophet,
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, and the rest
of us by extension,
he says that which translates to, "And
say, 'My Lord, increase me in
knowledge.'"
The next verse he mentions
is a verse in Surah Az-Zumar, verse
number nine.
This is a chapter of the Quran that the
prophet, Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam,
would read every night before he went to
bed.
Every single night before he slept, he
would recite Surah Az-Zumar.
And this verse is part of that chapter.
[Arabic recitation]
"Qul Hal Yastawi Alladhina Ya'lamun
Hadha Ismu Istifhamu Inkar.
[Arabic recitation]
Alamatuhu
Innaka Tastati' Ta'khudh Harf Aw Ismul
[Arabic recitation]
Ya'ni Mathalan,
Law Ahna Akhadhna Kilmatun Hal,
[Arabic recitation]
How you stack him in the manner you can
you can kill him. Well, la you stack him
in the manner you can
with la you stack him in the manner and
you can kill him so he can la. Stack him
in the manner you can with la you stack
him
for other is more ish. Is the fact I am
in car or is the fact I am not happy?
Well,
but la get the fact I am la the edge you
the manner and not happy.
Well, I am a black man with a jar of the
nut fee.
[Arabic recitation]
you stack him in the manner you can with
la you stack him in the manner you can
with la you stack him
real tough still with the suit and tie.
Can you cool have a man alone? But
the door is still I want to hack. Is
still I shock. I am jailed and Kabir so
we are that guy. On the
granny for care is still how you stack
him in the manner you can with la you
stack him in the manner you can with la
you stack him. Yes, you can enjoy
the nest so.
Well, I have men and a husband and
I let you enjoy
and is the fact I am in car. And in car
And so in this verse verse number nine
of Surat al Zumar Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala asks rhetorically
rhetorically.
He says
say
say to them, say to everyone, the Muslim
and the non-Muslims, ask them.
They'll tell you. Ask them.
Do those who know and those who do not
know, are they the same?
The answer is no, it's rhetorical.
It's if you say
to your son or your daughter, you told
them to do something, they didn't do it,
you say, "Didn't I tell you to do this?"
Right? It's as if you're saying even you
know this.
This is beyond being a question or
something open to debate. This is
universal truth. We all know this.
And so,
here Allah subhana wa ta'ala is telling
us that those who know and those who do
not know, they are never the same.
They're not the same.
No way.
As a matter of fact, even animals
that have knowledge hold virtue over
animals of their same kind that do not
have knowledge.
What is the most
severe or most extreme type of filth
in the legislation of Islam?
Something that is the most filthy thing.
Huh?
Al Khanzir
[Silence]
The most intense type of filth
is
the saliva of a dog.
Our prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
says if a dog drinks from your cup,
you have to wash it seven times. One of
those times with dirt.
This is very intense. All of the types
of najasah you could just wash.
Urine, feces, but that has to be washed
seven times even if it appears clean.
Seven times, one of which using dirt.
This is the
the
saliva of a dog. What does this have to
do with knowledge?
A hunting dog
a hunting dog that has been trained to
hunt
that has the knowledge of hunting is
exempt.
Is exempt.
No longer
does a person have to wash after this
dog seven times ihdahunna bit turab.
For rajih min aqwal al-ulama.
And so a hunting dog
is the same as the other dog. What's the
only difference? Knowledge.
That difference alone
that difference alone
changes its
treatment in the legislation of Allah
and the Quran and Sunnah and the laws of
Allah. How much more so the human being?
No way can a person who knows and a
person who does not know can they be
equal?
Sure, they could probably maybe be equal
on particular issues.
Maybe one will have an intention, the
other will have an intention, but even
at the at the base level of intentions,
knowledge is a prerequisite to sound
intentions.
In order for your intention to be good,
you have to have knowledge.
It is the key to everything. Without
knowledge, you have no hope of reaching
the heights.
The heights of Allah's pleasure.
And so those who know and those who do
not, they are not treated the same by
Allah. They are not the same in this
dunya, and they are not the same in any
logic or deduction.
And this is, again, all pointing towards
and bolstering the understanding of the
virtue of knowledge and its people.
May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and you I mean in
the name of Allah.
And you are
And
May Allah
bless and grant peace to our prophet
[Arabic recitation]